all right will
will uh where'd you grow up where you're
from originally
pennsylvania is where i grew up
um which part
york york
tell me about your childhood you grew up
with both your parents no i never knew
my dad until i was 25.
um
as far as i know the day he found out my
mom was pregnant he packed her bags and
sat him outside the door
um
[Music]
she moved around had me
in san francisco
as soon as i was born we ended up in
pennsylvania
and how was your childhood
rough
what were the rough parts of it um
mom was a drug addict
sold me for drugs twice
uh
i ended up in foster care pretty much
all my childhood
um
started using drugs
when i was pretty young
uh got into heroin when i was 13.
um
when i was 16
i became a father uh the day my daughter
was born i gave up i quit
um
i don't know something about holding my
daughter
something inside me just snapped you
quit heroin yeah
cold turkey i went home i grab i
gathered up all the drugs i had heroin
acid mushrooms everything
and i flushed it
i put a padlock on my on the inside of
my bedroom door and kicked the key
underneath
wow
and you've never used since
25 years
good for you
um i gave it up february 7th 1995.
last time i shot up was about 3 22 in
the afternoon
how'd you end up in the military
you enlisted
actually i was in my early twenties i um
i got caught in a stolen car
uh a pound and a half a hash two and a
half pounds of pot in the back seat
judge told me he could give me five to
ten on just the drugs he said i'd get
out of prison a convicted felon and
never amount to a damn thing
he says
or i could do four years in the military
and make something myself
so i went military
i started out in the army uh
actually at fort hood uh colleen texas
um
i didn't like the army i i waited term
and
i transferred to the marines
i ended up doing six years in the
marines uh two tours in iraq and one in
afghanistan
tell me about that
some parts of it was cool
getting to see the culture
[Applause]
some people
it was actually interesting i got to
learn a lot
but uh
there was other parts that
it was hell
i mean i know it's cliche to quote
war as hell
but
it is
um
our satellite communications specialist
for a recon unit
um
i was driving the lead
lead transport and a convoy in northern
baghdad
and we were ambushed
um
i remember i was driving
i
spun around pulling a u-turn and ran
over an ied
i woke up
days later in hamburg germany in the va
hospital
didn't know where i was didn't know who
i was
they said i was luck
i shouldn't be here
what are you showing me
all shrapnel oh you crossed your chest
and you lost your eye as well
the blast shattered my eye socket uh my
cheekbone was broken three places my
upper jaw was broke my lower jaw was
broke
um
all my teeth were shattered
my eyeball itself was punctured in two
places
my right lung had collapsed
um
i had shrapnel that was
millimeters from the ventricle in my
heart
i shouldn't be here
um
[Music]
that's not the first time i've
been injured in the field
i took a bullet to
my right knee that
it spiral fractured my lower my lower
leg and took out my left knee
that was in afghanistan
i've been
hell
i've been shot five times i've been
stabbed six times
i've been hung i've been poisoned
i've been hit by one mack truck one bus
four cars two motorcycles and five boats
i've jumped off of five bridges one
building two cliffs of mesa
out of 15 helicopters 146 airplanes
on top of being blown up
i don't know if there's a higher power
out there but
somebody's looking out for me
that's an impressive
list so today you're living on the
street
in hollywood yeah
with your wife
i always swore i was never going to get
married
been married two years
it's nice to have somebody out there
right yeah it's it's good to have
somebody that can actually understand me
i'm not always the easiest person to get
along with
i'm not always the friendliest um just
like everybody else i've got good days
and bad days
but uh
i've learned
a lot of ways over the years to
kind of pull myself back
when you were overseas
you got involved in combat
yeah
unfortunately it's
it's part of the territory
um
i don't know if it's like it for
everybody else
but
i still remember every face
there's
one
in particular that haunts me
um
[Music]
i was in
again in northern baghdad
uh
it was supposed to be a friendly zone
i was on a routine
routine recon suite
um
and i heard a gun [ __ ] behind me
so like any soldier i turned around and
shot first
there's a 12 year old kid with his dad's
gun
just
seeing that kid
struggling to breathe and taking his
last breath
it's
it's not easy to deal with
yeah it's got to be hard to carry around
with you
there's a lot of things i've done over
there that i'm not proud of
um
that
is definitely one of the biggest
have you seen therapists or done
counseling or anything like that
no um
i didn't want out of the military
really didn't
um
i caught a commanding officer raping a
12-year-old girl
and uh
i beat his ass
i got court-martialed i was charged with
striking superior officer conduct
unbecoming an officer insubordination
mutinous insurrection
they sentenced me to 90 days in
leavenworth
dishonorable discharge and kept him in
puts
puts into pretty good perspective what
uncle sam's really about
and
that's not the type of man i'm
i'm trying to be
my
my first tour in iraq
we had orders
it's a trash can
we had orders that uh
if it moved to kill
i'm sorry if it moved
kill it
man woman child creature didn't matter
if it moved
kill it
when i first got there i didn't
understand
those orders
and about three days in
a little kid couldn't have been more
than six seven years old
went into a bar we were all using as an
officer's lounge
he had a pound of c4 strap to his chest
nobody knew it
17 americans lost their lives that day
there was
i believe 23 civilians
and 17 americans in that bar
the only
the only survivor that made it out gave
a statement
the kid just walked up to a table full
of
soldiers
and said he was sorry
and he ripped his shirt open and
exploded
it's senseless
pardon the phrase [ __ ] like that
if i didn't know then what i know now
i'd have gone prison
instead of
i would have i would have gone to the
prison instead of military
would have been less traumatic
than you'd have your eye
i might
[Laughter]
all i know is i'm 41 years old
i've been around the world twice i've
seen every state except for alaska and
hawaii i've seen 14 other countries
i speak seven languages three fluent
i've got two college degrees
and i can't find a damn job to save my
soul
because most people
can't have this in the view of public
i spend my days holding a sign that says
kick me in the nuts for 20 bucks
it feeds my wife and i
and
some days puts a roof over our heads
[Music]
i've been through
more in 41 years than most people twice
my age
i
watched two kids born
and had to bury both my kids
you have two kids and you lost them both
how'd you lose your kids
my daughter was killed by a drunk driver
on her fourth birthday
less than six feet in front of my face
um
she was standing on the sidewalk
bouncing the ball
i looked away long enough to light a
cigarette
and a
drunk driver came up on the sidewalk
and ran straight into the house
smashed my daughter between the brick
wall and the front of his car
two months after my daughter was killed
my son's mother
put her daughter
and our son in the backseat of her car
and pushed it into the river
1999 was a really [ __ ] up year
my daughter was killed valentine's day
my son was killed april 22nd
he had just turned three
not to sound like one of the religious
nuts out here
but they say god only gives you what you
can handle
he must think i'm hercules because
i've been through a lot
will
how many people have you told this to
the only person that knows everything
like this
my wife
you've never shared this story with
anybody
no
not too many people are
dying to hear the story
i will thank you very much
this is where you guys sleep at night
unfortunately
and this is free
you're right off you're right off the
hollywood boulevard here
yeah we're right close to where close to
everything but away from everything yes
it's a nice quiet little spot
there you go
all right terry and will well sleep well
tonight
all right
i'll talk to you guys soon
thanks you guys
hi terry
you